yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby all
right yeah we're doing it again guys
we're back again doing it again fighter
and a kid 12 13 15 years going 27 years
strong 27 years later you have a child
sweatshirt on I have a the Mike drop I
have mik drop comedy sweatshirt on okay
they have different artists it's great
now um you to all for that sweatshir
though was in La Hoya right what's that
a little too old for that sweatshirt you
know how some can we but you know let's
get let me just say this I like the
sweatshirt it just doesn't it's not Bry
outy there is an elephant in the room
though and that's how good my face looks
right now can we get it is better yeah
is it moer anything but something's
different there's something different
about my face what is it well it might
be that I got some La Hoya sun on my
face right I thought some work done well
no no no I didn't get any work with done
you know it might also be the daddy's
not really he's dadd he's cutting down
on his saturated fat We Go Again Godot
better oh K feel a lot
better did you see his documentary not
doing cheese anymore I'm just did you
see the documentary on Netflix where
they take the two twins the set
different sets of twins feed one an
omnivore diet the other a vegan diet no
is it very interesting how long is it
it's too long it's too long you could
wrap that up in two minutes this tn8
veggies this tn8 steak this twin drives
a Tesla this one's living his life that
that's that's true oh one's hey one's
clearly gay well come on no those are
the the one that did the veggies is gay
right typically Iden cucum nope
typically identical twins are are if
they're gay they're both gay no that's
not true true there's a basketball
player uh Collins there's two Collins
twins they look exactly the same one's
came out as gay he's probably pretending
he's not gay then because they're all
gay all right so that's what I say
that's I'm sticking to that my my bro
scien is what happened with was the
vegetarian I don't know yet I haven't
got to it but I guarantee I guarantee it
was I guarantee the vegans come out on
top they even check their sexual stuff
well it depends it depends what do you
mean on top what do you mean Define on
top in other words their their lipid
panels are better their guarantee the
weight room not stronger I guarantee
they're not stronger I I bet you I bet
there's a number of things well the
problem is that so with meat you it's
easier to get iron and it's easier to
get B12 and it's easier to get certain
things right yeah you're not a cuck you
know that's the other thing you're just
not a I wish I could say the word but we
can't anymore cool you can't use that
word anymore but I want to really bad
right now it's tough to
say you tubes it's at the end of your
tongue hey hey now we can use our imagin
red flint sty listen me dude look
there's nothing wrong with with eating a
I eat a med Anan diet now it's about
fish it's about
vegetables I'm trying to think what I
care less about when someone tells me
about their diet or the
weather yeah but the only my D when I
call my dad he's like Denver today dude
we had a slight chance I'm like oh God
the weather yeah but I wonder if it like
so if you would reduce your cholesterol
decrease your
inflammation in other words you feel
better that's all it matters do you for
me it's like do I feel more energetic
and do I feel better I don't care what
you do but here's the thing if you think
you're going to live longer eating
plants might get a year on me correct
maybe two well how about this but when
you're 90 and you barely know where
you're at who give take me out well also
the the guy who is a scientist in
nutrition science at Stanford University
said everybody's different you know
people react differently to different
foods so if you say Vegan Diet is good
for everybody they're people that do way
better with meat you can't generalize in
that I I know a lot of really healthy
people who eat meat yeah you eat a ton
of meat dude I do I do you eat a ton of
dark meat what huh huh you don't know my
personal life yes I do you don't know
what goes on in The Recess of my imagin
my f household goes dark meat yeah right
yeah we have we just have dark meat
coming in periodically do we do we we we
bust it in only dark meat yeah I go to
only dark meat.com I go to cuck only
dark mecom only dark mecu.com
that has me a sight oh my god dude I
bought a car part off Craigslist
yesterday and met the guy oh boy thought
I was going to get shot yeah that's
interesting have you ever bought
anything off craiglist no I don't think
so it's it's it's a Strange Land there's
some good there's some gems on there you
got to search through yeah it's a search
through you can get dogs on there you
can get you can also hire a hitman on
there well there's a guy Wet Works you
get pissed on there's all sorts of stuff
yeah there are people there was that guy
who's killing people on it there there's
a there's a Craig serial killer so I
know all this stuff and I decided cuz I
need a different hood on my lightning
but I need a OEM Hood so a factory hood
y Lightnings are all over I'm sorry
F-150s are all over 994s are everywhere
so I was like I'm not going to buy an
aftermarket I'm just going to find one
on Craigslist boy yeah I mean there's
some rusted out some yeah dude it's 70
bucks but there's gunshots in it you're
like all right I can't I had things I
could probably sell for money I just
don't know how to I just cuz I got to do
doing that bad no no even if you're
doing well if you can make you though I
just don't have the energy is what I'm
saying like you know I'm not gonna well
my thing is is like I want a different
hood and there's I'm looking at the
price I'm like I'm not paying for that
I'm like I just want a regular freaking
Hood yeah and my brother's like go on
eBay but that it's you know they're big
Hood so shipping's like 400 bucks it's
more than the hood I'm like forget that
I'll tell Craigslist daddy old school
yeah I'll tell you what they're not uh
worried about
Craigslist or they're not on Craigslist
is is La Hoya especially on that on that
strand where you get to look at the
ocean I wonder what the Craigslist is
like at La Hoya there's some gems on
there's so much money in La Hoya there's
so much money there and and you know you
know the one of the attractions where
you go down there and you know where the
big sea lines are those big chubby sea
lines did you take a you ever go down
there and see that right on the beach
that's where I stay yeah giant giant fat
sea lions great white Central well so
that so that's their Buffet so here's
the thing all the Surfers and stuff
they're like guys that those are
artificial nurseries they they created a
sort of a seal birthing ground they kind
of they they they actually made that as
a a tourist attraction apparently and
they're like you're bringing in all the
[__] big gray whites and the SE surf
you can see the seals they're all like
I'm not going all the way out there and
the guy said we're going to get people
are going to get hit in La Hoya cove cuz
you're bringing these giant great whites
in with these [__] con sealed see I
know everyone talks about moving to
Texas Nashville wherever Montana you
been to oh come on now listen the and
the politics aren't the same down there
you got to remember La Hoya Red State
San Diego Red State it's red down there
OC red correct we're just in the woke
Central here but you get outside at La
like where I'm at Red correct La Hoya
red yes sir safe uhhuh Parts La Hoya
especially though oh yeah thinking about
La Hoya
though you better have some money you
you better have all the money you are
homeless out there bud correct no no no
they'd laugh at I was like I want to buy
a house they be like what's your
budget it's not happening they would
start laughing so hard when we talk
about if I do if I make this or this
gets sold I'm going to move to Tex I'm
move to Montana it's like go to La Hoya
and tell and tell me tell me in America
if there's a maybe Carmel up North but
they'd be tough to beat La Hoya if
money's not issue right yeah you all
that's taken care of now I'm not saying
a billion dollars but let's say you get
20 mil yeah you'd go to La Hoy well look
you'd pay the taxes to stain La it's the
weather's always amazing the beach is
always there in a best car scene in uh I
think in California really it may Texas
is good Florida San Diego La Hoya car
scene the best car shows down there so
you'd like this this guy can live
wherever he lives there see a guy I see
a guy he he's in a a Mercedes I've never
seen before I thought of you and I'm I'm
getting gas and I cuz I we took my my
wife's said Jeep and I and I'm looking
at this car and I see the guy and he's
probably my age but jacked out of his
mind and I'm like that's a disciplined
dude dressed well you know I'm like
that's a disciplined guy something about
that guy so you want to talk to him I
said to him but I saw this car I've
never seen it I'm going to ask you what
it is because it was a Mercedes I bet
before you even cover I bet you it's a
McLaren SLR Mercedes that's exactly what
the [__] it is that's exactly what the
[__] it is that one would get your
attention that's exactly what it is yep
that is 100 it's a track car yes that's
exactly what it is and I said my friend
is a psycho and he would be all about
your car and he started talking about
why he got it how few there are that's
exactly you you are correct yeah I KN
that is exactly what I saw they're worth
so much money now too dude he he uh he
said yeah I retired and then I got bored
I went back to you know doing my thing
and doing like he ran a trading desk you
know he's one of those it's a great car
and they're going up in value like crazy
really yeah dep so his was matte black I
know it was nasty and you see how the
doors open that is exactly it's a m m
too it's nuts they're so dope yeah I
know if it was a special Mercedes have
to be that maybe a black series for you
you know you're [__] cuz I didn't i' had
never seen that car but I said I think
Brendon would this would turn his head
yeah that's that's like the best
Mercedes and you could hear the engine
like it was
just I'm pretty sure it's a V12 and
they're not giving that bad boy away uh
no depend on the miles you're probably
looking at probably a mill 1.2 what what
oh so it's high mileage maybe 8009 so
homeboy got crazy money okay cuz I
thought so I could tell he was very well
to do especially now but I said to him
because I ran a trading I go I gotta be
honest with you you're in unbelievable
shape I mean Jack he was older older my
but jacked like you'd look at him and go
like I mean he just looked he wasn't
bodybuilder [__] he just looked like he
was a crossfitter he looked so good and
I was like how the [__] do you do this
obviously you know he's he's he goes he
a passion of mine you know just
discipline it is but discipline in life
dis car his body looked like his car and
I bet if he had if I bet he has tons of
cars that wasn't his one you're not
buying
McLaren he said he goes it's a passion I
just love cars I like this guy he's
talking about because it was the r
single they're only they're only I don't
know probably there are only a few in
the in the country you know this that
and the other thing and and he's like uh
and I go plus the power is different and
I go oh you one these guys you're crazy
you're just all about he goes I can't
help it it's what I am I'm in dude let's
take a little break dude take a little
break I'll be in uh
Nashville the end of this month January
Nashville is January 25th one night two
shows at zany in Nashville all right on
the 25th then the next night I head on
over to Austin January 26th and 27th
that is uh Aus I'm not I'm at the the
stepmother ship at the V with the Vulcan
gas company janary 26 27th with the
great Brett Forte come get you some and
Nashville tick at thi
boy.com uh guys CB live CB live Phoenix
Arizona Friday January 19 January 2021
come get some and then Louisville comedy
club uh that'd be February 9 and 10
Bricktown Comedy Club March 8 and 9
let's go brian.com for tickets now you
know sometimes you don't want to smoke
weed but you definitely want uh I don't
know a little CBD benefit you know what
I'm saying want some Buzz gummies yeah
that's why we partnered up with five
they give you free $40 bottle of the
five Daily Buzz gummies just pay the
shipping handling and then you get your
free freaking gummies we enjoy taking
them before podcast after training hard
or just for a chill little chill night
dude each serving of the five Daily Buzz
gummies contains two to 5 milligrams of
THC it's enough for you to feel it but
not get crazy they're called Daily Buzz
gummies because that's just enough to
give you a little buzz five is fully
legal and ships to all 50 states third
party lab tested grown in the US of a
and you can get it for free by visiting
5 cbd.com
fighter get a $40 bottle dude I like
this The Daily Buzz sour they're tasty
dude all right we have a box of them
right here we do that's 5 cbd.com
five you got to spell out five f i v
cbd.com
fighter Brian let me ask you something
how long has it been since you changed
the spark plugs on Tesla never done it
never done it well Tesla doesn't need
them that's right I hear parts are
expensive though uh they can be but you
should be replacing your spark plugs I
just did on the 2004 lightning 20 years
old and I needed some better freaking
spark plug so I went to O'Reilly o oh
O'Reilly that's right O'Reilly Auto
Parts gets get get you a $12 O'Reilly
gift card after rebate when you purchase
four more select AC Delco spark plugs
maintain your performance and fuel
mileage with the new spark plugs from
O'Reilly Auto Parts can also improve
visibility with new wiper blades right
now save your Tesla needs wipers you got
do $12 you can save on a pair of rainx
rugged XL wiper blades plus get two
times o rewards points an extra large
profile and premium features like rugged
XL blades the right choice for extreme
weather driving and durability the
professional Parts people will even
install your new wiper blades for free I
just said O'Reilly yesterday cuz I need
some parts uh replacing that new hood on
my lightning I have to go there and get
some stuff well then go to O'Reilly
auto.com O'Reilly auto.com o r e i l l y
auto.com o o
O'Reilly do different car store and I go
I said to him I go this is this is your
only car right he
goes you're not driving that every day
uh this going make the pot sad but my
in-law's best friends were over I don't
know them very well and they're super me
like the the mom speaks really good
English and the dad it's a little dicey
but like oh he's a car guy I'm like oh
cool so I got home late from things
talking to him and they're like yeah and
my uh my mother-in-law who she's not in
the cars she kept bringing up she's like
oh homberto she's like uh Bren just got
a a Dodge I guess he loves Dodge got
Dodge Demon he's like oh I love demons
blah blah he's like which one I started
telling her tears I'm like what I'm like
that's not that cool you know it's a
challenger it's cool
but I and I my wife said let me talk to
you their son a their son's dream car
was a a Dodge Demon cuz it came out in
2018 mine's a 23 so mine's a demon 170
but there's a demon 2018 that came out
that was his dream car but he had a
Hellcat which is great that 700
horsepower he had a Hellcat Challenger
and he was going to build it up like I
do build the car up in hopes to sell it
to get a demon and he passed away before
he did that 19 how'd he die Co he was
overweight and had uh really bad asthma
and got Co here's where they screwed him
is it it was early on they put a ventil
they put the ventilation the ventilator
on him and it speeded up the and it
killed him
a damn it what a disaster oh oh dude
Beyond a disaster oh I couldn't even
yeah no they're like go show them your
car like until you have kids you don't
understand oh yeah I've been in out of
the hospital non-stop your baby's having
some issues it's tough but um have we
talked about this on the podcast no uhuh
yeah yeah breathing issues so your baby
has breathing issues Y and they're
checking they're running a b making sure
she doesn't have uh face p h a c e face
syndrome yeah which is very serious well
know in three
weeks yeah it's been tough
ah it's uh super tough yep yep yep um
dude how about I got to change subject
start crying but how about my
three-year-old because we have a monitor
there my 3-year-old and uh 8-year-old or
7-year-old will'll be eight in February
they sleep you I make them share a room
share a bed KingSize bed they snuggle in
there they have to fight and do their
thing 3 in the morning Daddy I'm
awake and usually that means 5:00 a.m.
I'm like I'm always up at 5: so I'm like
I go on there I look at the clock I'm
like dude it is 3: are you out your damn
it's 3:00 in the morning he go well I'm
awake I I don't care dud you got to go
back to bed he go n I'm bored you're
bored cuz you got to go to sleep dude
everybody's sleeping he goes nah I'm
bored I dude you got to go to sleep and
he goes I hate you're not reasoning he's
four he goes I hate this house I wish I
didn't have this family I what' you just
say cuz I hate this house and at first I
was like oh hell no then I remembered he
watched home alone oh word for word he
used what Kevin mallister said Remember
When the mom makes him sleep with a piss
bed kid yes he goes I hate this house I
hate this family I wish I never had a
family she goes well you that could be
true
so all he did goes I hate this house I
hate this family that's so cute at first
I was like oh hell no but then I was
like and I started laughing like dude
you stole have from home
alone I love it so much so we were up
from 3:30 I've been up since 3:30 my
2-year-old will just do that he'll go
mommy daddy where are you I'm just like
well here we go yeah I'm up and racing
and he's standing up oh same thing every
morning Daddy I'm awake 3:00 a.m. I'm
bored the [__] what I'm bored bored and
he stayed up he stayed up me well once
I'm up I can't wake up and go back I'm
up I can but I I don't I'm usually up
between four and five every day every
day you are oh four and five especially
now yeah yeah yeah I'm up uh I'm up now
around usually six unless I haven't
sleeping I don't trust anybody who
sleeps in tell you that right now yeah
de Leah don't trust sleep when did you
get up go 10 I'm like what the f how how
what are you doing don't you have kids
what are we doing yeah
yeah who sleeps in over the age of 25
well I get up early so I can have a
little time to myself anyway that's my
favorite time that's why I don't mind
getting at 3:30 usually the kids not
awake but then I have it's complete
silence and if I'm at whatever cars
whatever I can just focus on that I'll
do all my I haven't heard much about
your fish bro you go from oh my fish are
thriving I just bought new fish no you
you're just not into them so I don't
share with you well I mean know just I'm
all I hear is truck truck trucky truck
truck and I don't hear anything about
fishy fish fishies oh no my ear w is 4
foot you're not over it hell no my fish
oh every morning bud yeah oh Bud fish
are easy to get ATT attached to I'm
attached to my koi I told you I feed
them oh no no no we I got aanas in there
now I got seven Oscars I got pacus I
just bought a turtle you got a turtle
now a turtle in there now I got a
catfish what I a catfish I bought him
that like this that [__] I love
watching them grow a shovelnose catfish
no one told me they get so goddamn big
he eats everything he's such a bully
does he eat your other fish
oh yeah that's a problem that turtle
head on a swivel Turtle really because
that catfish plays no games how old is
your catfish is I don't 8 months old
he's
enormous see that see that that's me
that's me every morning that's me with
my catfish every morning [__] so I have
to take food that big big chunks of food
yeah and throw it over there so he
attacks that and then feed the other
fish otherwise no e how much is really
nobody eats how much is the uh how much
food do you give them like like just
like a like a like a lamb leg or
something oh I have to buy live fish for
the aanas in him there's a lot going on
oh every morning in my house like
SeaWorld dude yeah how often do you have
to feed fish when they're juveniles
three times a day but what three times a
day three times a day and I love it
three times a day I thought like three
times a week no way dude I feed my fish
every day so they got to eat every day
the main fish they can go like a week
without eating if I'm like on the road
they can go a week it's not ideal but it
also cleans their system it's good for
the tank but I the the big like the
Arana is I feed every day they they eat
ton a ton live fish grow as big as the
tank or what no no really I'll have to
upgrade about a year yeah oh boy it keep
gr yeah nightmare no one tells you this
no but they do warn you at the pet store
they you'll see arijana in a tiny tank
it's like this big and they always go
they'll tell the parents ah those grow
pretty fast if you're going to just plan
to upgrade if you can get those they
should say Hey listen so that fish right
there I know he's 100 bucks right now
he's going up costume I don't know
probably about 5 G by the time he's
fully grown CU you have to upgrade your
tank the filters and I have two of them
what do you feed these fish does so you
got to feed you got to feed them cuz I I
have fish flakes that I feed my koi
that's for [__] fish yeah flakes they
would go the [__] it's like parmesan
salad they need they need real fish oh
buddy I I get I I have to go to the pet
store twice a week I just don't tell you
cuz you're not into the fish oh no my
life is fish and cars and kids dude fish
cars and kids fish cars and kids fish
cars and kids you know people are God
family yeah you fish cars and kids
church or whatever fish cars and kids
yes and you like it that way oh I'm but
at aquarium city of uh what is that off
Sherman Way I go they know my order I
have to I have to go twice a week dude
to feed these [__] fish see the big
man I have to get frozen fish I have to
get big monster pellets yeah I have to
carbon now what's daddy doing for for
his workouts
I should go to the gym up here lifting
weights yep just the basics deadlift
Basics deadlift pull-ups pull-ups bench
there you go that's it three times a
week that's it you don't need more than
that nah you go pretty heavy yeah yeah
that's it there's a guy who said I I
deadlifted squatted and bench pressed
and nothing changed my body more yeah
correct just heavy but those those
potatoes yeah everything else okay but
those three movements if you could only
pick three that' be the three they
changed this yeah
dude I watched a a documentary on that
that Gypsy Rose who got out dude you
don't realize how bad how evil her mom
was oh I do she escaped when she was 19
her mom lied to her cuz she wanted to
act more immature when she was 19 her
mom goes you're 14 she goes no I'm not
Mom I'm positive I'm 19 she goes no
you're not she changed her birth
certificate and made it look like she
was 14 and she goes I know you're full
[__] she killed this [__] or her
boyfriend whoa she she killed the
boyfriend stabbed the mom yeah but the
mom so she met some dude randomly at
whatever she was in like animation or
whatever or she went to ComiCon met some
dude they exchanged numbers she ran off
with him she's like I made a mistake cuz
he didn't have a car lived with his
friend so I was stuck yeah the mom she
goes out my cell phone dropped her mom
went through the cell phone found her
showed up to her house she's like it's
okay I get why you did this just come
home with me we'll make this right and
obviously she tricked her she's like
just make it right she gets home she
beats the hell out of her chains her to
the bed with legit handcuffs and a dog
leash for two weeks made her sleep next
to her so if she moved the mom would
move God damn two weeks and started
hitting her and then she and she she
would discipline me she said my mom like
would order my favorite food and eat it
in front of me and not feed me oh my God
what a witch now remember that there's
two sides of every story there's a truth
there's so when you were talking about
this I thought I thought I'd like to
hear from the mom cuz the mom might be
like this [__] wouldn't leave my side I
couldn't get rid of her talk about a
coock block I've been single for 30 [__]
years ID no I I don't think her mom has
a side however I do think I wonder if
that's that sounds very very creative so
I wonder how how true that part is there
they probably some artistic license
taken you think you think she
exaggerated a little bit maybe I don't
know but then again I wouldn't be
surprised if she's telling the truth
well because she had a cousin who said
she saw that he saw the marks from the
handcuffs and everything I believe it
and they didn't hear from her for two
weeks I believe it I believe it you hear
that God this mom's a demon but in my
head I'm like I'd like to hear the mom's
side yeah mom's like I can't ditch this
kid I tried going on dates and [__] this
little [__] block [__] she made her look
full special too I mean come on Mom her
teeth hat the way she dressed her oh my
God terrible just all so she could get
attention that so people would feel
sorry for you know they're in
Springfield Missouri that's where that
blue uh comedy room's at oh wow yeah
Springfield Missouri pretty sure yeah I
like Springfield what was that I just
saw about Casey an that's forther Cur
let's do a let's do a Golden Globes uh
segment Golden Globes did you watch it I
didn't did me neither good I saw my boy
Joe Koy did well okay who won chin the
Golden Globes yeah I I know I know
homeboy who dates Kendall won for or
Kylie that won for uh Timothy shal for
bear that movie the show bear on FX
Robert Downey Jr won yeah for
Oppenheimer he's amazing Barbie won
which is ridiculous San Murphy actor wow
Barbie great great uh movie Oppenheimer
one uh I haven't seen it yet have you
seen op I haven't I really want to see
it Divine the mcau ckins brother refused
to call Ali Wong won which is dope dude
nothing's better than our boy the comic
what's his name uh joeoy no no no
Christopher no no no no the the big
white dude we love him oh Shane Gillis
no Jim Gaffin oh yeah Shane Shane Gillis
wasn't at the Golden Gloves but Jim
Gaffin was he gets on there he goes I
can't his was the best he goes I can't
believe I'm here I don't really fit in I
can't believe I'm entertainment and
everyone starts clapping he's like this
is so special I can't I just can't
believe I'm here cuz I'm not a
pedophile what and he just waits to Bean
goes so this next award incredible oh
the best I just the best do you know Jim
at all the best I know Jim yeah I don't
know Jim well but I've known you I know
him me and him would would DM and then
he bumped me at The Comedy Store and and
they're like hey do you mind just going
too late because we have a special guest
I'm like what the I got to get going man
I got another set I know we just have to
do it this guy you know he's kind of a
big deal I'm like who is it and I hear
over my shoulder hello Instagram friend
I turn around it's Jim gapin like what's
up dude he's the best hello Instagram
friend yeah just he's big he's big he
just lurched over my shoulder goes hello
Instagram friend she like I'm from
Indiana go I know what you're thinking
Indiana
Mafia anyway a little bit more about me
I'm from I'm Korean I'm from Korea and
then he goes actually I wish I was
Korean then then my interest in Asian
women wouldn't be so creepy
so [__] hilarious he's the best yeah
Jim's one of the great stand-ups period
oh of all time Seinfield now he's
incredible his uh Hot Pocket bit I mean
legendary yeah legendary yeah I've been
I've been the voice in uh in uh was it
Transylvania 3 I think I was doing shows
with him like you know I mean in New
York when we do these like open mics or
remember one time I was Jim was was
ahead of me and we were there was this
like it was like Diner or something like
shitty restaurant and it was like you
know people were sitting down it was
like just kind of basically an open mic
sort of and and this guy said something
to Jim and he had a mustache and Jim
goes sir I can't talk to you because you
have a mustache and it smells like
poo like just these little things guys
he just
funny yeah the Golden Gloves I just I
watched some I watched joeoy
opening uh mon I didn't see it happy Joe
Joe had a couple Digs at Taylor Swift
and apparently she got a little pissed
she wasn't feeling it and left early he
had a good joke though it was a funny
joke I don't mind it I wonder if she was
pissed or he was like g glo's a little
different cuz we're not going to show
Taylor Swift as much as the Nel does but
she did not look happy when to her hat
she hated it mm well you know oh no oh
no no oh no yeah people were like oh
that all that look had to do to ruin Joe
Ko's career I'm like oh you don't know
how Big Joe Co is in our space that he
does Arenas you stupid idiot yeah flies
private so shut up he's crushed it crush
it literally it's like if a comic's
flying private they're just fine yeah
they're doing all right yeah I am not
flying private no I did the other day
but I didn't it was in my plane yeah
I've done I've I did the other day too
wasn't my plane and then when talking
about private jets like I was on this
private jet my friend was like do a
video you on the private jet and I was
like I'm not doing that I don't like
posting those things sounds I took a
picture of Tiger cuz he was on there he
could have given two [__] he doesn't
know better he's like what yeah I know
better boy I'd love to be able to fly
private all the time no lines it was
nice [__] would would you like something
to eat no there's no food on yours there
was yeah different on my friend's
private jet I've never been on a private
big enough plane where there's ranian
flight attendant like gorgeous gorgeous
like a we have um we have the Shakur
plate we have I mean it's just
unbelievable you're talking about a mile
high lizard Lot I'm talking about Mile
High lizard Lot yeah yeah I know what
you're talking about I haven't been on
one of those ples yeah well oh dude I I
atat vegetarian last night speaking of
the the cuck vegetarian kid I I uh I
want something different in uh my boy
Travis Barker owns Crossroads yeah great
Resturant there's one in Calabasas now
so we ordered from there it was
fantastic it's good sign me up for the
vegan
I could eat that every night that place
is amazing hit my pants but I could eat
that every night yes you could what were
you saying I said that place is really
good it I'm I'm like not into that vegan
food stuff but everything here was good
it's Crossroads is outstanding I
actually ate there with Travis Barker
slight Flex okay I was just there and he
was he's such a good guy you know him
pretty well right yeah a big car guy ah
the squash blossoms were nice the yeah
everything's pretty good there yeah
man you be a special kind of Chef to do
all vegan huh yeah the chef here's my
thing if I go vegan I'm going vegan I'm
not getting their fake sausage they have
the fake you know pork chops no no no I
had the salad the kale salad was nice
you know
yeah yeah now is it better than a steak
house no no no a lot of times if it's
not prepared perfectly but they they did
a they do a good job there mhm
like I'm not getting the calamari there
you know what I'm saying no no they have
calamari too I'm like I want real BR I
don't know it's you know it's always a
derivative it's like a it's like a
gluten derivative it's like a Satan or
Tempe or you know or cashew nut butter
you it's like it's a lot it's heavy it's
a lot of fat a lot of calories yeah lot
of got be careful with that just people
think they're eating vegetan put onight
there's a ton of
calories oyster mushroom mushroom
mushroom yeah so it's something totally
different we're just calling it but it
has the same texture chewy like a like a
octopus yeah I don't need U that many
you di but you di enough freaking
marinara it's all the same yeah everyone
knows calamari's Pig anus yeah it's Pig
anus it's Pig asshol it's forkin
everyone knows that you think Outbacks
cutting up octopus I'm not into uh think
Chili's is kind of
octopus what do you think it is it's
just Pig anus it's Pig anus cheap
cheaper you got do some with those booty
holes pig lips and pig Anis yeah yeah
everyone knows that oh we didn't talk
about they announced Anthony Joshua
Francis
andana so a couple couple things I text
our group chat with you me Joseph Rogan
Eddie I it's official yeah AJ you got
Francis the world has AJ Bryan That's
not breaking news right but it doesn't
sound like you guys did on my thread my
it's and I said this on the shop show I
posted it it's a much more challenging
fight for Francis now Tyson Fury is a
better boxer Tyson will beat anony
Joshua the reason why it's going to be
more difficult is the cats out of the
bag the element of surprise is gone yeah
he had that against Tyson I thought he
won the fight he didn't whatever he's
had his best showing against Tyson Fury
CU Tyson can say what he wants he didn't
train for that fight he looked awful
that's right he didn't take him serious
by round six like oh [__] I better pick
it up here and if I'm going to win and
notice he won the later rounds he
started boxing
anon's going oh he can actually box I'll
get ready I'll get ready so now you're
fighting a real Anthony
Joshua in the Olympics yeah I'm not
saying he fought a fake Tyson Fury I'm
saying he fought a uh uh Tyson Fury who
was overlooking him guy you're talking
about guy who's going to be in great
shape who's probably weighs what 250
when he fights 240 240 see what he
weighed the last fight Anthony Joshua um
yeah and very very I think anthon
Anthony Joshua was GNA be like I got I
got to train for real otherwise I'm get
knocked out thing is also but to to the
caveat that the reason why me and ran
were saying that in the group chat is
Anthony Joshua gets hit he
does 25 his last fight he's 251 yeah all
body that's yeah all body he's not big
in Francis though no Francis was 272
yeah Francis it's crazy Francis crazy
here the thing Anthony Joshua I don't
care he always gets hit so that's why he
the the odds are better for this fight
than they were the fury fight now the
odds are better because again the public
knows how good of a box Fran the cats
out of the back yeah they he's ranked
top 10 wco so he's ranked top 10 in the
world we know he can box so the odds
aren't minus 4,000 anymore for Joshua
now it's minus 500- 700 it's where it's
still a big favor which he should be but
they're closer I think I think uh plus
500's fair but the reason why Francis
can still win this fight where the the
fury one I gave no chance he win this
one because Joshua gets Joshua's not a
slick mover like Tyson he gets hit I
always go to this it's not so much that
I always think I would imagine and I
would I would I would suspect and expect
that because Anthony Joshua has been in
the ring longer at boxing he has an
ability depending on fight IQ to
actually read what Francis and cono is
going to do after like say round four so
other words he starts figuring out what
his Tendencies are starts figuring out
what his patterns are he has to Cave
that has to get to round four he's got
to get to round four but but but but but
again a more experienced boxer is able
now to cut you off the pass get you
stepping where he wants you and and and
Tyson Fury is more experienced than
Anthony Joshua yes but Anthony Joshua is
a schooled boxer and he works at it so
so is Fury more fights more experience
yeah again Fury just didn't take it as
seriously maybe but again you got to
give Francis Credit yeah we can't just
say Fury look bad no Francis can [__]
box and Anthony Joshua I don't care who
you are if if unless you're Tyson Fury
who has the best chin of all time Joshua
doesn't Joshua's been knocked out many
times he Hein supect no he's been
knocked out his Chin's suspect yeah but
he's been more he got knocked out in
training I know that before the I think
the re fight um but either way I think
he's he should be able to outbox Francis
angano I think he should be able to
knock Franciso out ultimately all of
them can outbox Francis the difference
is why I like Francis chance in this
fight is cuz Anthony Joshua takes risk
he stays in the pocket cool
cool do against Francis let me how it
goes for you mhm so a punch his chance
of Francis yeah he has a way better
chance to be Anthony Joshua when he did
Fury way better way better have you Fury
doesn't get hit there get hit and he
does he has a granite chin he gets back
up be let's take another break this
episode's brought to you guys by
Progressive Insurance yes most of you
listening right now are probably
multitasking yep you're listening do me
and Brian chat about nonsense all right
your cleaning your exercise or maybe
even grocery shopping a deep squat who
knows who knows but if you're in some
kind of moving vehicle probably don't be
doing this but there's something else
you can be doing right now get an auto
quote from Progressive Insurance it's
easy you could save money by doing it
right from your freaking drivers who
save by switching up Progressive save
nearly
$750 I'm going say that again $750 they
save on average and autoc customers
qualify for an average of seven
discounts so discounts for having
multiple vehicles on your policy being a
homeowner and more okay Progressive will
be with you
247365 days a year so you're protected
no matter what multitask right now quote
your car insurance at progressive.com to
join Over 28 M million drivers who trust
Progressive Progressive cash insurance
company Affiliates national average 12
month savings of
$744 by new customer surveyed who saved
with Progressive between June 2022 and
20 May 2023 potential savings will vary
discounts not available at all states
and situations well here's the thing man
our friend Mike Clover we got to get him
up on spent 18 years in the US Army and
as a government contractor doing stuff
that you guys don't need to know about
that's right but a real badass a real
hero very very intelligent and he's
created this content um as well as other
subject matter that experts uh basically
talk about when it comes to preparedness
be prep Round Up solutions to building
out your preparedness plan that is what
fieldcraft survival is about that's what
the app is about I have I have a set of
his uh fieldcraft survival kit in my TRX
it's awesome dude I I brought it with me
to San Diego actually they will have
intro level education that built into
advanced topics so no one is left out
it's stuff you think you're you think
you're ready you're not you have not
trained for it and things happen so you
know from selfdefense Jiu-Jitsu medical
survival Bushcraft Family prepar Y
disaster that's a big one and they go
from beginner to advance so each topic
is there's a it's a structured Master
Class style format to help you at
whatever skill set is to become you need
to become more prepared and it's good
stuff you think you're uh you know
prepared for this stuff and you like I'm
a black brown Jiu-Jitsu no you're
learning something and like you and I
started off in the beginner yeah and you
got to be your own first responder so
one thing everybody who's an expert that
says you are your first response people
don't come they're going to come to you
in 20 minutes an hour 40 you never know
but you are your first resp resp yep you
get it's a monthly subscription you get
30 days free all right you're going to
wish you had this if things hit the fan
you get a monthly subscription get 30
days free use the code fighter3 all you
got to do is fieldcraft survival.com
that's fieldcraft survivor.com Fighter
the annual subscription 35% off of
annual subscription use cod use code
fighter
35 you don't wish you had it that's crap
survival fieldcraft survival fieldcraft
survival.com I actually have the book
that I'm reading now and I'm loving it
what do you got Jen uh you guys were
mentioning comedians earlier so I'm
hoping you guys watch the cat William
stuff yes on the sh sh sharp that
podcast has 33 million views yeah I
watched it like a day ago was that 20 33
million views and cat went bad on Rogan
he was saying how he just has onfunny
comedians on that he pushes he never
have me on tweet I was like I'd love to
have you on I'm a huge fan come on come
on on very good that's the great way to
do it but he went on yeah on a lot of
went off dude talking about yeah it's
strange never I love Kevin Hart so I
don't understand that you know that's
says in 15 years in Hollywood no one in
Hollywood has a memory of a soldout
Kevin Hart show they're being aligned
for him ever get a stand Ovation at any
comic Club he already had deals when he
got here have you heard of a that came
to LA and in his first year in La he had
his own sitcom on the network television
had had his first year own film called
Soul Plane that he was leading no no
we've never heard of that before this
person or since that person what do you
think the plan is what do you think a
plan is maybe people don't understand
the def definition of these words he
just did his documentary with Chris Rock
where he shows you that his whole
upbringing in comedy was on the East
Coast so how simultaneously was he here
in Los Angeles doing the same thing it
didn't happen well he's wrong for 5
years perod every single move that Kevin
did was a movie that had been on my desk
all I said was can we do take some of
this uh [__] out and then can I do it I
don't need to be uh overtly homosexual
because I'm not a homosexual doesn't
need that to be funny and me saying that
and them going oh yeah no problem and
then going to give it to this other guy
and having him doing it just like it was
and acting like I'm a bad person because
I keep standing on my standard they tell
you there's no Gatekeepers but we keep
seeing the same person open the gate
didn't Kevin let Tiffany adders in what
do you mean ain't no gay kers there's a
100 Gates out there everyone I seen got
a keeper so let me just respond to this
since I I was I was there for the whole
time I was there when Kevin Hart wasn't
famous I was definitely there when
Tiffany hadish wasn't famous I've known
Tiffany hadish since she was 17 so it's
somebody who is an eyewitness to this
Cat Williams doesn't know what the [__]
he's talking about and when it comes to
Kevin Hart no one works harder no one
worked harder Kevin Hart did every
single improv every single [__] club
for years well over 10 years probably 15
before he hit it actually but let's say
10 years and when I say he did it every
show every Club Kevin would go and he
would collect every email he followed
the Dane Cook thing he had somebody who
would actually go from person to person
collecting emails when they were
standing in line and that's how he built
his following he also built it by being
[__] hilar ious Kevin Hart is
hilarious never stops being hilarious
and the third thing I'll say about Kevin
Hart another thing I've witnessed with
my own eyes many times whether it was on
a set with him for a month whether it
was um hanging out with him in a club
hanging out with him in a bar I've done
two movies with him no one's more
generous no one's more generous to
everybody no I think for I've seen that
dude just really quickly I saw that guy
we were we were at Montreal we're
hanging out having a laugh this waitress
this kind of like she's just sweating
and she's this little blonde weight just
going back and forth and freaking out
she was just doing her best to try to
service everybody she was just it was so
hard for her and Kevin reaches into his
pocket and he takes out $400 and just
without anybody seeing it he puts in his
hand he goes thank you so much for all
your hard work tonight no one heard it I
did because I was next to him that's who
Kevin Hart really is so Cat Williams
just doesn't know what the [__] I think
C Williams doing this right 33 million
views he went he went against every big
name so this can get traction he goes on
Kanye Cedric the Entertainer stealing
jokes he goes in on Harvey Weinstein
wanting to suck his dick at a meeting
Steve Harvey some of the stuff he said
was funny makes sense
but a lot I don't know about that I I
think a lot of it is jealousy like you
you read that like ah come on cat cat's
so talented and he's been the his own
demise like he's the funniest cat in the
world no pun intended but then a lot of
it are his Stakes can you go can you go
up a little bit cuz right here they
cancel me for talking about Harvey
Weinstein before this thing this thing
came out but he offered to suck my penis
in front of all my people at my agency
what am I supposed to do he did all of
that I'm thinking I'm the only black
person on the script I get there it's
three other black guys on there huh I
told them no what y'all do I like all
right I don't believe that but
okay
ah yeah he's a strange gu thinking about
Steve Harvey's funny it is funny goes
you can be a you talk about Steve Harvey
goes you can be a movie star there are
30,000 new scripts in Hollywood every
year not one of them asked for a country
bumpkin black dude that can't talk good
and look like Mr Potato Head whoa okay
was hard in the paint bro Steve Harvey's
hilarious not that one but then he's
killing it Chris talk we have now did he
the Chris Tucker that we have now is
Epstein Island Chris Tucker not smokey
Chris Tucker didn't want want to be the
poster child for smoking weed he don't
smoke weed like that he he in the church
he Michael Jackson's best friend Michael
Jackson called him Christmas you ever
met a man that gave you a nickname like
that on Diddy I came in this business
saying I was going G expose when I
talked about Michael Jackson when I
talked about AR Kelly they cancel me for
these things because why would you talk
about another black dude race is not
where the line is drawn it's God's side
and the other side and we don't care
nothing about the other side period
period all these big big dick deviants
is all catching hell in 2024 it's all up
for all of them I don't it don't matter
if you Diddy or whoever you is TD Jakes
all of them all lies will be exposed you
know he he's a he's had a history of
drugs apparently so Michael blackon my
boy I like Michael most comedians don't
get booed enough that's how you end up
with Michael blackon who is a real
African doing a fake African accent if
you're the African king of comedy sir
let's actually
there's actually comedians in Africa
doing comedy if you're going to say that
you got to go to Africa and get a school
he does have a school Michael blackon
has a school in Ghana you got to put it
put in some work and these guys they
take my advice they change their whole
Persona and then they hate me for it
blacksman responded to Williams in a
series of tweets on January 3rd saying
among other things Cat Williams is a
very smart [__] he took shots at sound
like a black guy while you're reading
this right I'm not he took shots of the
10 10 ComEd top 10 comedians alive today
so we can all respond and make him
relevant relevant again he's right the
Jonathan major one that's actually
pretty funny who's Jonathan major just
Rec from I don't want to get I don't
want to get with a white woman because I
was scared she might have me running
down the street like Jonathan Majors not
because I don't like women I think white
women are as great as any other woman
but I'm not going to act like I'm not
scared of them I have a reason to be
scared you could be Kang the Conqueror
and they can take you your rabbit ass
down on two weekends first of all they
went around the world for two years
straight telling any woman that would
listen that this was a good-look negro
since when when did y'all start liking a
big nose when did y'all like a little
head and a big jaw when that look like
my daddy when you start liking my daddy
you like black people's features like
that um if this ugly nword is goodlook
then all n words is goodlook thank you
meing good thank you God bless you for
Save coming to save that slave if he had
to be there by himself he was getting
all four guilty guilty guilty she came
in there just so beautiful they had to
knock half it off bless his heart wow no
read the Rogan one Joe Rogan Joe don't
want me on the show Joe got six means
that never been funny he want to push
out um [__] you I'm funny he's one of my
favorite comics and I'd love to have him
on Joe said we we have we talk about him
all the time if he's down I'll make it
happen yeah people people are DM Meo
he's talking about you you've been on
there more times than anyone I'm not on
there for comedy relief I'm for my fight
science there's no but I'll tell you
he's not talking about me he's at The
Comedy Store a couple times he is a
genius oh cat is a here's the thing I
want no heat hey Cat I'm with
you who your enemy is my enemy when he's
on when Cat Williams is on as a com best
he is as
good ever stepped on anyone who's ever
stepped on a [__] yeah he's top 10 he's
just he's just a little he's a wild boy
I saw him I mean I one of the few people
I've come up to and said I was like bro
I didn't really never seen him I go
you're so so good he did 20 minutes and
I was like [__] M there's more but um
he's amazing this is what Kevin Hart
responded with got to get that anger out
you champ it's honestly sad in the
meantime please enjoy my movie trailer
of my next film lift which will be
dropping Netflix in 8
Days yeah then he goes there's a moment
in the trailer where I don't know who
this is says they really love you says
they really love you I now know she's
talking about cat Maro calar world this
one is special yeah I C Williams it's
tough he's brilliant you hate to see it
actually it's all really funny though as
long as your name's not mentioned what
if he was like Joe Martin Lawrence
Martin tried to put me in my first dress
when he had to go on his Hiatus he' tell
me cat when I come back I need you
you're my younger partner you're my
brother in comedy when I come back just
promise me that my next movie it'll be
me and you we're going to do it together
we're going to do buddy cop [__] I said
Martin you got my [__] word
my blah blah blah go do what you got to
do when you come back I'm your I'm in
your movie don't trip I don't need to
see the script or nothing you know we
get in that office and this fool pull
out Big Mama's House too I almost died
and I got to read the script in front of
all these good white people where this
nword want me to get in a dress with him
he's saying there's some sort of thing
like Illuminati once they put them in a
dress then they start like they're what
no I don't Oh I thought you were going
to say
yeah something about like once they put
you in a dress whoever the higher powers
are that's when you become successful
but then you're selling your soul to the
devil basically this is awesome he's and
he's trending I think Kevin Hart said
he'll never be in a dress and then they
showed him in SNL later in a dress and
then he start a B I know this is
obviously you know but I mean that's
what he said and also with ludicrous
just cuz uh ludicrous did a rap uh he's
saying that him and Luda were invited to
this one thing and uh Illuminati party
right there was a Crossroads where we
both both invited to an illum naughty
thing it had to be one or the other of
us the decision had been made so it was
both of us we were equal one of us had
to cut off all their hair and couldn't
do a Sideburn thing no more with the
points and the next person they said was
going to get 200 million because they
were going to pay him 10 million movie
to do 20 movies that's how the
conversation happened one of those
persons turned out to be ludicrous other
person turned out to be Cat Williams
it's hilarious and then so this is the
hey here's my thing what have he's
telling the truth it's kind of funny
it's like sprinkled with l see what L
says whatever's heavy on my heart is
always on my mind like snoop's cannabis
Shredder I'm always on my grind they
Throwing Shade cuz [__] could never
take my shine I bring my watch
collection on my jet let me take my time
like fine wine I'm aging like Benjamin
top five I'm worth mentioning bring me
rappers I'm lynching them see the
pendulum swing Jesus with diamond Thorns
ludicrous swallow in Gucci Linens when I
was born never been Illuminati only
udati and I only left with [__] when
coming from any party now I'm married
with kids the evolution of life never
been a cloud chaser never say [__] for
likes R John Singleton you never have to
flex when you earn every one of your
Fast and Furious checks afro with The
Sideburns yeah that's my signature
Addictions on the rise comedians check
your
temperature I love him he's so good I
love him yeah I I like LR John Singleton
died yeah wow the director yeah he did a
hot second ago Dude how did he die I
think some sort of illness
damn that's not in your Tik Tok John
Singleton man he's a great director yeah
boys in the hood [__]
dude how old was he damn bro he died
he's my age man he died four years ago
don't act like you're all hurt by it you
just found out dude you piece of [__] oh
man I'm such a fan he had a stroke four
years ago like comes to me goes man I'm
such a fan when's your next fight I
go that's what you're doing right now
with John
sing oh man I'm so bummed died four
years ago piece of [__] D 2019 oh man ah
he fcking five years
ago oh what am I going to do didn't you
do training day I can't go on ah no he
didn't do training day I got I can't do
the podcast you guys I got to take today
off all right what do you got Jen uh
this kid here have you seen this kid no
uh he's 335 pounds I
think I don't know if he's he's like
college I guess but uh check him out oh
my
[Music]
God so 335 lb and he runs a 1297 in 100
meter that's insane it's not that fast
it's not I guess cuz he's so huge and
the other people are just you know tiny
yeah at 3:35 though no yeah he's moving
for 33 let see again let me see again
did you not see how two white guys are
ahead of him that's not good they're
tiny though yeah but it's not good when
two white track stars in front of you
it's not good these times aren't fast I
think I it's impressive cuz he's 335 lbs
my Lord he's big there he is yeah that's
a big fella he's athletic
oh yeah what is this yeah that's
fast he's a three star recruit what does
that mean he committ to Oklahoma what
does three star recruit mean it's out of
five okay so three three solid is it
because like when kids um like you were
saying when kids peak in high school
they get to college and everybody starts
speaking Pros they it's like yeah they
get eaten alive yeah you got well or you
just you just peaked early like LeBron
James and LeBron Peak early he didn't no
he's the best high school basketball
player at 14 wasn't he yeah that's I
mean he peaked he was just better than
everybody right but LeBron's 40 still
leading the league in 38 years old is
that crazy it's crazy but but um so so
in football though like you get this
Phenom like that and a lot of times they
don't I don't know if he's a Phenom he's
only a three star
recruit I mean his size he's big but I
would call him a there's the Phenom sign
was CU they got the number one
recruiting the nation o lineman so that
would be five star five star five star
is going Alabama Ohio State Colorado now
yeah five stars going big boy big boy
Oklahoma's I mean he's he's has to be
pretty D those guys are all five five
star
yeah Al
righty don't know if you guys saw this
but Alaska Airlines had a little bit of
trouble in the air um the door flew off
in the middle of the flight so insane
weren't you always told that the door
it's just for the movies and people
don't get sucked out apparently it
ripped this kid shirt off yeah he's
like I mean you you could you could get
sucked out of the plane too look at that
that's so freaky if on those people next
to I'm like can I
move I was told you can't open those
doors when the when it's in the air they
come there's a plug that's supposed to
be in the door that was missing and
they're saying it's because of that and
then some a teacher in Oregon was like I
found this in my backyard and it was the
plug to the door whoa yeah so they're
looking into
it and you know what the airlines did
nothing my bad yeah us going to be late
yeah I'm going to fly somewhere else we
don't care yeah have you guys ever been
on a plane when the masks drop never I
mean I feel like if that happens we're
you just think you're going to die never
that I mean that I'd be like hey can I
fly for free for life I almost died I'd
like to fly for life also those people
that were just just still there chilling
with the door open my friend my acting
teacher was in a plane crash that went
into the water and it was a famous plane
crash in uh in LaGuardia it was the
winter time he gets he goes in the water
uh I think 41 people died damn he hits
the water he was in first class and he
he hit got knocked out and then just
came to when he saw people underwater he
was underwater and he [__] gos to the
top of the water and because the jet
fuel was the water there it is that's
the one talking about flight five 5 5
probably that he starts breathing it the
70s he starts
breathing um and he's breathing in jet
fuel so he starts going to like no it's
all true it's all documented 27 people
died he climbs up on the he climbs up on
the on the Rocks it's winter and he's
like can't breathe and a guy who pulls
up to him is going to save him you know
he's the guy you know the truck and he
goes bro you're the guy from the [__]
he's like he can't even talk he gets
recognized damn only half the people
died says 92 that's crazy no this was uh
maybe it was 92 I don't
know yeah but it was yeah crazy
92 my Richard Richard Lawson look him up
Richard lawon Survivor of plane crash he
was a soap guy he was in a
poltergeist Richard Lawson Richard
that'd be a bad way to go plane crash
yeah oh so he he was
there he is right there he dates
Beyonce's mom or he's married to her or
something he's he's one of my favorite
acting teachers ever and I'm going to
tell you a story about him in a second
yeah survived yeah the US Air flight 405
plane crash right in the
water he's a bad [__] man I love
him so much yeah so he crashed in
'92 Flight 405p type in Flight 405 plane
crash in
'92
look at that how scary would that
be wait go back CH because it it gave
the 27 people died 24
survived so he was really special so he
used to teach a class right from 7 to 12
at night twice a week that I was in I
was in there for
years and it's been there you know I
don't know how many years he taught me
and he's one of those those amazing
acting teachers who would be like he I
do a scene and he'd go like this he' go
so what are you doing over here dancing
[__] and I was like I don't know he goes
he go like this he goes not good really
everybody yeah I mean he'd kill you
right but he was always right and so one
day somebody said to him um you I've
never seen you
yawn in class I mean we're here from 7
to 12 and you have a full day I've never
seen you yawn and you I've never seen
you act tired and all of us kind of
realized after I don't know how many
years we were like that's actually true
never heard him fart well but but I mean
never seen him like drag never seen his
you know I write about this you know my
standard but I never saw levels are good
yeah never right and he said um cocaine
nope he said um well I was a medic in
Vietnam and I learned some things well
what does that mean he goes I was a
medic for two years two tours yeah they
got be up nonstop it wasn't that it
wasn't that he said um one thing I
noticed is when I would when I would
tend to American
soldiers when they got injured a lot of
times they would go into shock I never
saw a Viet guy go into shock I could he
could be he had they had the same wounds
you could even see like you know lungs
you could see everything and they they
would they would stay lucid and you
could interrogate them they wouldn't
they weren't screaming they so when you
go into shock what happens is all the
blood rushes to I guess the core your
body and then you die shuts down really
bad right he said they weren't dying
they just didn't go into shock it's
[__] crazy and so he said he just was
like this makes no sense because they're
they're smaller they're suffering the
same injuries and they're able to to
deal with it and you know we're all
you're like what what what what anybody
have an idea of why you think that is
it's really interesting just tell us man
so he he he did an investigation he
started talking to to the Vietnamese who
were on the South Side you know who he
was fighting along with and they said
well you Americans um you make
yourselves the center of the world so we
don't think of ourselves that way I'm
just a leaf on a on a very big tree so
the minute we get injured we're taught
to put our attention over there and by
the way our attention already is over
there we're never concerned with us so
if we're hungry we're cold we're tired
it's very very secondary it's an
afterthought for us because this doesn't
count as much this this is just like
this is just my physical body my em
tired though so so he learned that he
said when I'm here teaching all my
attention is over there I never care
about myself he does give a [__] about
how tired is he never indulges he said
I've never indulged after that I learned
from these this Vietnamese monk this
Buddhist monk he goes after that I
learned to never ever put my attention
on myself ever in any way said I just I
only like all my attention is always
over there and you would see it with
this [__] you would talk to him
and he's he would i' never got he's he's
big big guy you know handsome guy big
look look down on you and when you talk
to him he's like right here listening to
you that's why he was such a good
teacher because he could see everything
you were [__] doing everything you
were doing and and you'd be talking to
him and he'd be like sitting there
looking at you and you're like this dude
I'm the only person on the planet and
this girl was talking's that's it this
girl was talking to him and she goes I
can't talk to you and he goes why she
goes you're just you make me feel all
and he goes I'm just communicating with
you she goes I know but you look you see
right through me I was like he does he
does that's cool it's kind of cool yeah
what else you got Jin all right this is
sonaz but I'm not going to show it on
air I don't even watch it yet this right
here oh [__] yeah I don't I mean I don't
even know I don't need to say anything
oh I'll just play it then let's see the
video first
US who's recording it help him out
exactly [__] oh they're fighting yeah
wait for it oh my gosh oh that that kid
who hit him is going to get I mean
that's involuntary manslaughter right is
it or was he defending himself no that's
murder yeah that's murder I don't want
to watch the rest but like let's let's
say he hit that dude that he just he
didn't fall on the train track but he
hit his head on the concrete and dies
that's murder let me see go go back to
that I want to see did actual crash
again no I want to see the fight I don't
want to see the guy die I just want to
see what
happens okay so he was put his hand on
him but that guy hit him first yeah but
he had his hand on
him it's going to be tough to say
self-defense you killed a guy well he's
pushing him it's in New York though he's
probably out tomorrow it is in New York
if it's La New York you're out tomorrow
Philadelphia Philadelphia same you're
out oh for him see
that yeah that's just tough to watch man
yeah you got to be aware of do it say
what happened to that guy who hit him in
the did you read it
chin um no last it doesn't say anything
not
yet uh police say the man died on in the
incident Person of Interest was arrested
at the next station yeah he got arrested
for
sure yeah yeah I don't know how it's
going to go down cops say they are
investigating the man's death as a
homicide he'll probably get
um I mean he we tried for murder with
the defense there I watched too much
show there is self-defense though right
cuz the guy was going like this first of
all he has his hand on him he faking to
hit him he's and he goes like that when
you do that that is a he's being violent
that guy was was defending himself that
guy said this guy's going to hit me boom
hits him but you can't kill he fell over
into that thing he's going to he's not
going to get uh he's not he's going do
some time he's not going to do life
maybe maybe I think it'll be
self-defense depends on this to see Team
I think there a lot
of lers take that cas a heartbeat yeah
there could be so many of much bigger if
he was like I was just chilling the
guy's way bigger I just chilling this
guy's trying to I to defend myself I
didn't know he was going to fall in the
train track yep he's way bigger all that
stuff they can't make little little
fences there or something cuz that looks
so dangerous for anything now people
need to get on the train I agree I know
but they're open when the train arrives
cuz people can get pushed off like no
problem it's scary man
yeah that's
Christ listen yeah okay little football
time so I don't know if you guys watched
the Saints Bucks game the other night uh
last night Saints lit him up not Saints
Atlanta sorry Saints Atlanta not only
did the Saints light him up but they ran
the scoreboard up at the last minute so
Atlanta's coach lost it when the coaches
met in the center he got pissed got
pissed he tore into him and here got
fired then he got fired this morning but
here's where it gets weird so James
Winston's coming out saying this was a
team decision but the same coach came
out and said that is not the decision we
had as a coaching staff we would never
support that kind of decision that's not
who we are so it's bad taste in other
words to run the score up yes well the
coach probably gave him like take a knee
or just run the ball and he's like n and
called it his own shot and threw a
touchdown and neither one of them's
going to the playoffs so it's like where
was this energy during when the games
counted next one you'll show the video
of the I see Atlanta coach no we're done
down yeah she' be at the Bott very
interesting man I love I love the NFL
for that in a lot of
[Applause]
ways look how happy Winston is watch
Arthur SP hot that Dennis Allen scored a
touchdown at the end he is hot he said
what are you do he
goingn that guy in the Hat who's mad got
fired this morning
know to Allan yeah so here's Dennis's
response and I'm gonna start off by
apologizing to Arthur Smith and the and
Falcons um that was not a play that we
intended to run down there to finish out
that game that's not who we are that's
not how we operate we got a good rivalry
um and and it's a heated rivalry um but
there's a way we go about doing our
business we should have taken a KNE so
what are your thoughts Brandon I think
Jameson just wanted to score he's the
backup right so I mean what can you do
he can't it's also if if you didn't like
it stop it it's also kind of fine but
also if you're Atlanta Falcons stop it
it if you don't like it stop the play
yeah there's also that there's also that
there's the defense there's also like
the defense that point you've lost and
it's like you're already getting your
ass whoop one one more Miami hung 60 on
the Broncos you think we like that I
agree you stop if I'm the coach I'm not
saying that my bad for letting the score
run that way my bad yeah I think it's
more of an unid rule like it's not done
what are the Falcons what's the Falcons
uh what are their what is their they're
awful their season no it's over the
season's over playf they he won three
games I think one of the worst teams in
the league you're getting fired no he
got fired already this morning he got
fired the coaching Carousel has begun
Ron Rivera got fired too from the
commanders Ron Rivera for the Washington
uh Redskins uh got fired and then
commanders Atlanta coach got fired
Chargers coach got fired the Raiders
coach got fired Jim Harbaugh who plays
tonight Michigan uh Championship he's
leaving going in the NFL hopefully comes
to the
Chargers last I heard it was was hardbar
to the Chargers or the Raiders but then
belich being thrown into both as well
Eagles lost keep bich out yeah no we
don't want Eagles are so bad one of the
worst what's but they were so good now
and now they're injured right so and but
but the quarterback uh Jaylen Herz is
injured hurt his finger and then their
star receiver AJ Brown got hurt too so
Philly's not winning this sh they're
probably lose they're get knocked out
this first round yeah wow who are they
playing first round who are they
playing yeah was it Cowboys are doing
well oh they're playing Tampa at Tampa I
think Cowboys have a home game they just
need to they're horrible on the road
good at home but they should have two
home games depending I think both the
Cowboys games would be home games but
yeah they don't lose on their own turf
no I still think it's going to be Niners
Raven Super
Bowl uh I like Buffalo Niners man
Buffalo looks good the one six in a row
big Josh Allen fan Josh Josh Allen's a
stuck Buffalo fan you hear that guy
talking about Josh Allen the the guy on
Miami no the offensive coordinator I
think or maybe the coach there offensive
coordinator he's like he he reminds me
of Elway he's just he's even bigger yeah
like he's a stud Wyoming product is that
what it is MHM I think the the bills it
gets colder they playing that cold
weather that's got to be a factor you
know it's a big factor hard to grip a
rock when it's being thrown at
you those guys are hard I root for Miami
I like Detroit to do
well I don't like I don't I don't like
Baltimore I never liked Baltimore the
Lions did the Lions win yesterday
yes they should they should have beat
Dallas they screwed
him I think everybody wants to see the
Lions do good it's been a long time they
done
anything what else you got Jen I know my
football last
one this
one so I guess this happens often Bass
Pro Shop people like to jump into that
pond which one is it the one in
Springfield yeah this is the Big Daddy
one oh this the one I went oh no this
one's in Alabama the biggest one's in
Springfield look at him yeah oh but yeah
so the video is pretty
cool this stuff is whatever but we'll
see do you
think that yeah I got that he did
Cannonball he did a
cannonball his butt naked mhm well that
one
more he went again kind of belly flop
there just terrible body nobody ever in
shape jumps into these things do they
he's lucky there's not like polar bear
some [__] sounds like
it so I'm going to [__] your
wife those Bass Pro Shops are so
impressive yeah they really are he's
having a real meltdown this guy yeah he
is and keep watching that's when you
know shit's not going at a Bass Pro Shop
that's when things aren going weird
place have a m look at that security
guard making 26 an hour oh that's not
good that must have hurt so oh
no if you're just listening the dude
attempts to get out of I don't know 12
foot aquarium jumps out and eat
[__] he's hurting he's he's hurt this
guy's got the taser ready dude tase when
you got that wet
dick yeah he's not doing things are
that's Rock botom right there see that
that's in the movie that's the Rock
Bottom you know how they say like you
got to get your [__] together dude you
know they say there's even wiggle at
Rock Bottom I don't think so that's the
lowest I've seen especially especially
ending it with that belly flop onto the
[__] concrete
conrete ah probably farted too and he's
just out just knocked himself out making
that
noise then they got to drag him away
yeah that's not good oh well there you
go leave a long poor guy that's his job
[__] security guard is like God damn
it they probably liked it they're like
there's something to do finally yeah you
know we're usually arresting people for
feeding the flamingos or some [__]
unbelievable that's is that it chin
that's it live from see kids I'm in
Miami this Saturday um I'm doing a
corporate gig but it's open to the
public at the JW Marriott um and then
I'm going to be at the uh where am I
going to be Phoenix Arizona CB live and
then Louisville Comedy Club Louisville
Kentucky dude you're missing the fight
campaign with uh Joey Diaz that hurts my
20th it really hurts me that really
hurts doing a fight campaign for the big
UFC pay-per-view January 20th Rogan Diaz
Eddie Bravo myself and then the keep on
trucking tour kick off in Nashville one
night only January 25th at zany's two
shows one night and then that Friday
Saturday the 26th 27th I'm in Austin
baby back in Austin at the stepmother
ship I'm at the Vulcan gas company
theater January 26 27th get your tickets
now thick boy.com all right kids love
you